good afternoon
the
9027th meeting of the security council
is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is maintenance of peace and security of
ukraine
the agenda is adopted
[Music]
i would like to take this opportunity
to thank on behalf of the council
ambassador barbara woodward permanent
representative of the united kingdom for
her service as president
of the council for the month of april
i would like to express the council's
appreciation to ambassador woodward and
her team for the skill with which they
conducted the council's business last
month thank you barbara
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the representatives of germany
greece
italy
latvia
poland
slovakia and ukraine to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
on behalf of the council
i welcome
his excellency
mr piater glensky deputy prime minister
and minister of culture and national
heritage
of poland
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
mr martin griffiths under secretary
general for humanitarian affairs and
emergency relief coordinator
michelle bachelet united nations high
commissioner for human rights
and miss tatiana lauzon advocacy
coordinator right to protection
it is so decided
mr griffiths
miss vashelay
and miss luzon are joining today's
meeting
via video
teleconference
the secretary general will now begin its
consent sorry the security council will
now begin its consideration of item two
on the agenda and i wish to warmly
welcome
the secretary general
his excellency mr antonio gutierrez and
give him the floor
madam president excellencies
i welcome this opportunity to address
the security council on my recent visit
to the russian federation and ukraine
where i met with president putin and
president zielenski on the 26th and the
28th of april respectively
as part of my original visit i also had
discussions with president erdogan in
ankara and president dutta in reserve
poland
throughout my travels i did not mean
words
i said the same thing in moscow as i did
in kiev
which is exactly what i have repeatedly
expressed in new york
namely that
russia's invasion of ukraine is a
violation of its in territorial
integrity and of the charter of united
nations
and that it must end for the sake of the
people of ukraine
russia and the entire world
madam president
i visited moscow and kiev with a clear
understanding of the realities on the
ground
i entered an active war zone in ukraine
with no immediate possibility of a
national ceasefire
and the full-scale ongoing attack on the
east of the country
before the visit the ukrainian
government issued an appeal to the
united nations and to me personally
expressed publicly by the deputy prime
minister regarding the dire plight of
civilians in the devastated city of
mario paul
and specifically the azov style plant
in my meeting with president putin i
therefore stress the imperative enabling
humanitarian access and evacuations from
besieged areas
including first and foremost mario paul
i strongly urge the opening of a safe
and effective humanitarian corridor to
allow civilians to reach safety from the
azov style plant
a short time later i received
confirmation of an agreement in
principle
we immediately followed up with intense
preparatory work with the international
committee of the red cross icrc
along with russian and ukrainian
authorities
our objective was to initially enable
the safe evacuation of those civilians
from the azov stall plant
and later the rest of the city in any
direction they choose and to deliver
humanitarian aid
i am pleased to report on some measure
of success
together the united nations and the icrc
are leading a humanitarian operation of
great complexity
both politically and in terms of
security
it began on 29 april and has required
the enormous coordination and advocacy
with the russian federation and
ukrainian authorities
so far
two safe passage convoys have been
successfully completed
in the first concluded on three may
whenever the non-civilians were
evacuated from the azov style plant
along with 59 more from a neighboring
area
in the second operation completed last
night
more than 320 civilians were evacuated
from the city of mario paul and
surrounding areas a third operation is
underway
but it is our policy not to speak about
the details of any of them
before they are completed to avoid
undermining possible
success it is good to know
that even in these times of hyper
communications
silent diplomacy is still possible
and is sometimes the only effective way
to produce results
so far in total nearly 500 civilians
found long-weighted awaited relief
after living and the relentless shelling
and scarce availability of water food
and sanitation
the evacuees have shared moving tales
with you and staff
mothers children and frail grandparents
spoke of their trauma
some were in urgent need of medical
attention
i hope that the continued coordination
with moscow and kiev will lead to more
humanitarian pauses to allow civilians
safe passage from the fighting
and aid to reach those in critical needs
we must continue to do all we can
to get people out of these hellscapes
and the secretary general and the
emergency leave coordinator martin
griffith will brief you today in greater
detail on the latest efforts in mario
paul and additional steps
my commissioner partially will brief on
reports of violations of international
humanitarian and human rights law
possible war crimes and the need for
accountability
as i discussed yesterday with president
zielinski the u.n will continue to scale
up humanitarian operations save lives
and reduce suffering
madam president
my meetings with most leaders also
focused on the crucial issue of global
food security
and indeed the worldwide implications of
this war were in full view in my
subsequent travels to west africa
in senegal niger and nigeria
i heard direct testimony from leaders in
civil society on how the war is
unleashing a food security crisis
we need quick and decisive action to
ensure a steady flow of food and energy
in open markets
by lifting export restrictions
allocating surpluses and reserves to
those who need them and addressing food
price increase to calm market volatility
but let me be clear
a meaningful solution to global food
insecurity
requires reintegrating ukraine's
agricultural production
and the food and fertilizer production
of russia and belarus into world markets
despite the war
i will do my best to help facilitate the
dialogue to help make this a reality
at the same time
the war in ukraine in all its dimensions
is setting in motion a crisis that is
also devastating global energy markets
disrupting financial systems and
exacerbating extreme vulnerabilities for
the developing world that is precisely
what i established why i established the
global crisis response group on food
energy and finance
to mobilize u.n agencies multilateral
development banks and other
international institutions to help
countries face these challenges
we were particularly engaged in making
proposals at the spring meetings of the
imf and world bank
madam president excellencies the war on
ukraine is senseless in scope
restless in its dimensions and limitless
in its potential for global harm
the cycle of death destruction
dislocation and disruption must stop
it is i time to unite and end this war
and i thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
briefing
i now give the floor to mr martin
griffiths
linda madam president
thank you very much indeed um
as we've just heard from the secretary
general elements of
diplomatic progress are coming into view
even as
civilian suffering mounts
so i'll speak briefly today if i may
about the human toll of this war
and then about what we're doing to
address humanitarian needs
including a short update date on our
latest operations
and i know that high commissioner
bachelet will of course detail the
impact on civilians
for you i will be brief
just to recap the district
destruction of civilian infrastructure
has come to characterize this conflict
apartment buildings schools and
hospitals in populated areas have been
attacked
and they must not be so
over 13 million ukrainians have been
forced to flee their homes of whom 7.7
million are displaced inside ukraine
lives have been uprooted ripped apart
and never will be the same again
and many others couldn't run
often the most vulnerable
are simply stuck
the elderly people with disabilities
have been unable to seek shelter from
bombs get out to gather supplies or
receive information on evacuations
and the threat of gender-based violence
including conflict-related sexual
violence
sexual exploitation and abuse and human
trafficking
as i'm sure we'll hear from the other
briefers risen hugely the war began
allegations of sexual violence against
women girls men and boys
are mounting
roads as we've all seen are heavily
contaminated with explosive ordnance
putting civilians at risk
and stopping humanitarian convoys from
reaching them
madam president let me
briefly brief you what the un and our
humanitarian partners
are trying to do inside ukraine to meet
these growing needs
we have
217 humanitarian partners with whom we
are working in ukraine
and i think we have now scaled up at
record speed we have more than
1 400 staff un staff
deployed across the country
operating out operating out of eight
hubs beyond kyiv with staff houses and
supplies
in 30 locations principally of course
across the east
where the war is happening and the needs
are greatest
we reach more than 4.1 million people
with some form of assistance
on a daily basis across all the
countries 24 oblasts
our humanitarian response has three main
aspects
first we deliver a great deal of
humanitarian assistance and protection
services to displaced people and i know
it's not enough and i'm sure it's
adequate and i know we'll hear more on
that
but that's all across the country
especially where internally displaced
people have sought safety
or where people begin
have begun returning a crucial crucial
new element to severely damaged
communities and when i was an european
just a few weeks ago the mayor was
describing to us
as he i think described the secretary
general
how
his people are trying to get back to
europe
but to do so the reconstruction will
take as he's put it a year and a half
so restoring basic services necessary
survivors is key and i was very struck
by the fact the international committee
of the red cross
very very quickly
after the conversation i'd had but not
as a result of that went in to repair
the basic services element for the
population of european to be able to
return
in these areas injecting cash aid allows
civilians to choose what they need and
offers a modicum of dignity in these
precious times
it helps to keep markets open and
liquidity and supply chains moving
we plan to reach 1.3 million people with
cash assistance
plugging into ukraine's social
protection system with top-up payment
working with the government working with
the prime minister and his plans for the
distribution of cash to his people to
reach family at risk
this is needed technically but it's now
largely achieved and cash-based aid will
now scale up
very very quickly indeed
a second part that's the first part the
second part of our response is working
on pre-positioning supplies to forward
operating bases
and increasing our preparedness in areas
to where we think
we imagine this war might move next
and third
we've heard from the secretary general
we engage every single day
with parties to the conflict to push to
the movement of aid to civilians in
areas of active conflict or to negotiate
to help civilians leave for safer areas
we have been able madam president so far
to stage five interagency aid convoys to
some of the hardest hit areas
operations which required the
humanitarian unification system to both
parties to allow for those safe passage
movements
they've been a lifeline a small mercy
perhaps to civilians encircled by
fighting bringing in medical supplies
water
food rations non-food items
and so forth
but it's a beginning
but hopefully it's not an end
and as the secretary general has
described as a result of his own efforts
we've seen a glimmer of hope in these
past days thanks to his efforts and
those of our colleagues
uh on the front line as you know on may
the second
more than a hundred civilians were
evacuated from the azov style plant in
mario
including women children and older
people
about 60 more people joined that convoy
on the outskirts of mario paul and were
then able to move to safety and it was
as the secretary general has described
a project of the greatest complexity
and of constant constant oversight and
it was an exceptional operation i'm
especially grateful i'd like to record
here our thanks
to the international committee of the
red cross and the leadership of peter
mara as well as to our own
highly highly experienced first
responders but i must also applaud the
authorities
and
essentially the respective militaries of
both ukraine and the russian federation
for their close and constructive and
essential
cooperation in making that operation a
reality
it showed us
that that can happen
and i believe
though the numbers weren't great that a
single life saved is worth every ounce
of effort
and as of yesterday as the secretary
general said we were able to move more
than 320 civilians out of the mariopol
area broadly again working closely in
lockstep with icrc and with the
cooperation
of the ukrainian and the russian
authorities
and today we have that third operation
which began this morning
with the intent of evacuating civilians
civilians
from mario paul and azam style and as he
said we prefer not to speak about that
operation until it is complete
what i can finally say about this is
we're seeing the fruits of our labor
over these past many weeks
of establishing a liaison in in moscow
of the visits that preceded the
secretary general and which were
brought into fruition by his own
long and detailed meetings with the
leaderships of both sides in this last
week
we are beginning to see now
the agreement on local ceasefires
because none of these movements are safe
passage will happen without local
ceasefires pauses windows of silence
so we're making some progress and we're
building relations and we're building
experience which we hope we can then
broaden uh to more such operations and
that is the third element of our
humanitarian program we'll keep pushing
for more civilians to be able to leave
mario paul and indeed as of style if
they say choose and we'll now begin on
that basis to explore options for
reaching others where the need is
greatest and where we
need and desire to serve the people of
ukraine in their hour of direst need
madam president thank you very much
i thank mr griffiths for his briefing
i now give the floor to miss michelle
bashley
madam president
excellencies
for over eight years since 15 march 2014
my office through the human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine has been
monitoring the situation in ukraine
today we have released close to 50
periodic and thematic reports on the
24th of february 2022 we quickly adapted
to a very different working environment
like millions of ukrainian the staff of
my office relocated to other regions in
the country but and i'm very proud to
say have not paused their work for a
single day
currently the mission has staff on the
ground in uzgora kiev
dinipro
donetsk and odessa and conducts uh field
bases to various parts of the country
including kiev and sharnegie region just
last week
the mission continues to verify
allegations of violations of
international human rights law and of
international humanitarian law in the
context of the russian federation's
armed attack on ukraine
many of these allegations concern
violations that may amount to war crimes
based on the mission war my office
updated the u.n human rights council at
the end of march and will present a
report on the human rights situation in
ukraine covering the period from 24
february to 15 may at the next session
of the council in june and my press
technology on the 22nd of april
summarized our most recent findings
it pains me to say that all our concerns
remain valid and the situation keeps
deteriorating
madame president today is the 71st day
of the escalation of the hostilities
expanding the already eight year-long
conflict to all regions of the country
reports of deadly incidents such as
attacks on hospital number three and the
drama theater in mariopol on the railway
station in kramatorsk and residential
areas in odessa have become shockingly
frequent there seems to be no end in
sight to the daily reports of civilian
death and injuries my team on the ground
conveys the palpable trauma and shock
experienced by people they speak with
the mass majority of whom have either
personally witnessed a violation or a
victim themselves
rather than try to describe what victims
are going through let me use their words
residents of mario paul set up a
telegram channel to share information
about the relatives who perished in the
city and i will quote them
he was killed in front of his wife and
children
her body remained under the debris of
her house we could not even bury her
my uncle died from loss of blood after
sustaining fragmentation injuries i only
know he was buried in a collective grave
i could share many more such messages
last week on the 28th of april when the
u.n secretary general was visiting kiev
to meet the president of ukraine
voldemort zelensky the city was hit by
two missiles at least one woman a
journalist was killed and four civilians
were injured in the attack
an oschr team was in keep on that day
too preparing to visit busha on the same
day we corroborated 22 civilian death
and 40 civilian injuries in other places
of ukraine
members of the council in ukraine my
office has recorded
6731 civilian casualties since the of
the 24 february we know the real figures
are considerably higher
as my office consistently reports most
of these casualties have been caused by
the use of expressing weapons with wide
area effects in populated areas such as
shelling from heavy artillery including
multiple launch rocket systems missiles
and airstrikes my office is also
documenting the devastating consequences
of the conflict on other human rights in
areas around key from late february for
about five weeks
russian forces targeted male civilians
who they consider suspicious
men that were detained beaten summarily
executed and in some cases taken to
belarus and russia
unbeknownst to their families and held
in pre-trial detention facilities
my staff met with families who are
searching for their missing male
relatives desperate to know where they
are if they are alive or how they can
get them back
families were shot as as they tried to
escape in convoys in some areas it was
dangerous to cross the street with
snipers or soldiers shooting at anyone
who tried
local authorities are compiling lists of
death and missing continuing
exhibitions taking dna from relatives
while also trying to reconnect districts
districts to electricity and water
in other areas controlled by russian
armed forces and affiliated on groups
such as
kharkiv donetsk luhangs separation and
herself regions we continue to document
arbitrary detention and possible enforce
disappearances of representatives of
local authorities journalists civil
society activists retired servicemen and
the armed forces another civilians by
russian armed forces and affiliated
armed groups
as of 4th of may my office has
documented 180 such cases of which five
victims were eventually found dead
we have also documented eight possible
enforced disappearances of people
considered to be pro-russian in
government-controlled territory
my staff heard about cases of women
having been raped by russian armed
forces in areas that were under control
as well as other allegations of sexual
violence by both parties to the conflict
and yet the stigma around rape and
sexual violence continues to prevent
victims and their families from feeling
safe to report
this only highlights the importance of
ensuring adequate and safe support
services for victims
grim evidence of torture ill treatment
and summary executions of prisoner of
war committed by both parties to the
conflict is surfacing my office is
collecting such evidence which will be
included in its future reporting
the only way for these horrors to stop
is for armed forces to fully respect the
obligations under international human
rights law and international
humanitarian law
it is vital that all parties give clear
instruction to their combatants to
protect civilians and persons or develop
the combat as well as to distinguish
between civilian and military objects
those in command of armed forces must
make it clear to their members that
anyone found to have been involved in
such violations will be prosecuted and
held accountable accountability demands
that evidence be preserved and that
mortal remains be treated with tendency
with decency
madam president members of the council
the list of gross violations of
international human rights law and
serious violations of international
humanitarian law continues to grow each
day
and we cannot let the number of victims
continue to rise
a one-day ceasefire alone would spare
the lives of at least 50 civilian
children women and men including many
older persons a one-day ceasefire will
prevent 30 to 70 civilians from being
injured and the doctrine from being from
becoming disabled
a one-day ceasefire would allow several
thousand civilians to safely leave areas
where they are currently trapped in
hostilities
most importantly a ceasefire will show
that a horror in ukraine can be stopped
it is of the most fundamental importance
that the ongoing hostilities ceased once
and for all
but i'm president advocating for
accountability is a cornerstone of my
office work if the perpetrators of
violations against civilians and persons
or the combat are brought to justice
potential perpetrators will think twice
before unleashing similar unlawful
attacks or or acts of violence and
creating new victims
accountability also contributes to the
healing process for the victims the
family and the society at large
national justice systems are the most
crucial i urge the parties to the
conflict to investigate all violations
of international human rights law and
international humanitarian law allegedly
committed by the armed forces and i
welcome ukraine's efforts in this regard
my office is fully committed to
supporting those systems and the work of
the commission of inquiry on ukraine and
to cooperating with the office of the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court another international justice
mechanism in accordance with our
established u.n frameworks let us commit
to putting a stop to this senseless
conflict we must be steadfast in our
efforts for peace and resolute that
justin will be done i thank you for your
attention
i thank miss spatula for her briefing
i now give the floor to miss tatiana
lauzon
thank you madam president
it is a great honor
to represent today's civil society
that mobilized the first hours after the
full-scale russian invasion of february
24th
as they did before
for eight years of the war
our joint efforts are aimed at
supporting brave ukrainians
fighting at the forefront
as well as in public offices in live
kiev and kramatorsk these are volunteers
municipal workers planting flowers in
kharkiv and other cities in ukraine
under heavy shelling
railway workers evacuating people away
from hostilities and death
bakers cashiers at groceries and all
people affected by the war
all ukrainians are now beating as one
big heart
in the chaos of war
no one should be left behind
people their lives and health honor
dignity and security shall always remain
the highest value
in order to maintain this goal ukraine
and the whole civilized world shall face
immense challenges caused by the
military invasion of the russian
federation
the war has been lasting for eight years
in 2021 the number of idps in ukraine
clean occupied territories of crimea
donetsk and luhansk regions officially
was almost
1.5 million
at the end of april the international
organization for migration informed that
the number of internally displaced
persons as a result of the full-scale
invasion of the territory of ukraine
reached 7.7 million
they all carried the same heavy burden
of displacement
they all need equal protection
also should not be forgotten those
ukrainians who were forcibly displaced
to the russian federation
from marijuana
and other citizen villages
these people were forcibly displaced
without documents and means of
communication exposed to the filtration
by the russian federation
within these two last months
over 1 million people overall
and around 200 000 children among them
were forcibly displaced to the russian
federation from ukraine
it must be ensured that those who are
willing to come back to ukraine or
travel to other countries have the
possibility to do so
challenges the children and their
parents experience in the face of war
are overwhelming
right to protection received calls by
our hotline where parents were ready to
send their children abroad with complete
strangers
out of desperation because of the
russian atrocities happening in kharkiv
marijuana and other cities
the world was shaken with stories of
little boys aged even four or five
crossing the state border alone
or in the best case canaria will barely
familiar people
ukraine as well as accepting countries
shall resume responsibility over these
vulnerable little ukrainians so that the
children are safely crossing the state
borders supported by specifically
trained state guard officers and child
service representatives
the accepting countries shall guarantee
a high level of their protection
family reunification should be presumed
and they are safe and timely returned to
ukraine of the after the end of the war
must be insured
the number of killed and injured
civilians is permanently increasing the
destinies of dozens of thousands of
people in marijuana her son kharkiv
chernike erpin are unknown
relatives cannot always prove the death
of their beloved
even if they witnessed their last
moments themselves
international communities shall assist
the government of ukraine in
establishing and enforcing appropriate
measures of investigation and
persecution
since each life is priceless
and relatives deserves to know the truth
i want to mention those ukrainians who
have fled ukraine seeking safety and
security in the european union and other
countries in the civilized world
these ukrainians overwhelming majority
women and children
should not be overlooked
in terms of observance of their rights
shelter human trafficking access to
service including psychological health
stateless persons and third country
nationals who had previously found
refuge in ukraine
shall be granted protection alone with
the ukrainians
finally of paramount importance is to
recall the immense number of adps
many of whom may not have a roof over
their heads
in many cases the conditions of
temporary accommodation do not comply
with basic rules of adequate shelter
idps live in collective or transit
centers established in schools places of
common use often not designed for state
during cold times
over 32 million square meters of house
and property
were destroyed damaged or occupied
despite the massive destruction as the
whole world has seen in bucha
thousands of civilians either returned
back or never left their damaged homes
all of them
urgently need adequate temporary or
permanent accommodation
especially for the cold autumn and
winter periods
those who choose not to leave their
damaged homes shall receive the much
needed tangible support
such as the construction materials and
tools
plastic wrap and physical health
additionally such unprecedented massive
destruction of civilian infrastructure
requires durable solutions
from the ukrainian authorities with
support of the international community
we call on all members of the security
council
international organizations
and governments to support ukrainians
firmly in these dark times
in the name of millions of people who
have died
unborn survived residents of ukraine
a u.n member since 1945
we require to rephrase and brief new
sense in the u.n universal declaration
of human rights
all human beings
are born free and equal in dignity and
rights
for a living in peace
thank you for your attention
i thank miss lausanne for her briefing
i would like to draw
the attention of speakers to paragraph
22
of note 507 which encourages all
participants and council meetings to
deliver their statements in five minutes
or less
in line with the security council's
commitment to making more effective use
of open meetings
i now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements
i give the floor to the representative
of albania
thank you madam president and may i
start by congratulating the uk
presidency for for their excellent
stewardship of the council during the
month of april and wish you man i'm
president india linda
as well as the u.s team the very best
for this month
i'd like also to thank the secretary
general for his remarks for his clear
positioning in upholding the
international law and even more so for
his efforts to negotiate a safe passage
for civilians in mario paul during his
recent visit to russia and ukraine
we all must be proud of what the u.s
system the u.n system is doing to help
ukraine and its people i'd like also to
thank usg griffiths high commissioner
bachelet and miss luzon for their
important and updated information yet a
sobering one
madam president
the absurd unprovoked unjustified and
still going on war of choice of russia
and ukraine is in its third month
while russia continues to be immured in
total denial the world continues to
witness a never-ending human tragedy
despite worldwide calls there is no end
in sight
calls for a humanitarian pose during
orthodox easter
were unheeded
the war continues to inflict and due
pain on ukraine and its people
indiscriminate shelling and bombing of
population areas
the killing of civilians and attacks on
health facilities schools and civilian
infrastructure continue
as extrajudicial killings sexual
violence and rape actions that may
amount to war crimes have been
documented and are mounting as we heard
by usg
griffiths
eastern and southern parts of ukraine
are now facing severe consequences
while airstrikes continued in multiple
areas in ukraine causing additional
damage and civilian losses
every time we meet here there are new
reports of casualties news of more
atrocities uncovered and more
destruction inflicted
just like that apartment hit in odessa
killing eight civilians including a
three months old baby all those dreadful
accounts just mentioned by the high
commissioner bashlet
but russia's actions are not limited in
ukraine only
more than 5 million people have been
forced to cross the borders
no one could have imagined how quickly
the world's bred basket could go from
wheat fields to battlefields
global hunger is soaring to alarming
levels exacerbating like never before
this but never exacerbated but like
never before by this war that is
destroying a country that is aggressing
developing countries and it's
challenging the entire world
dear colleagues
1 200 bodies have been discovered so far
around kiev
and almost all civilians
killed by a bullet in the head
you remember
kremlin considered ukrainians as
brothers and yet it is killing them
when you kill your family you are a
monster
soldiers have tortured raped and
murdered only to be honored for their
bravery
they should be called to account not
celebrated
as russia stalls and keeps redrawing his
strategy
all indicates that these abused
commanders have abundant military
military drug dream
and to prove any form of success are
flattening cities and terrorizing
civilians
this is the victory alarus when you
cannot prevail on the battlefield you
resort to atrocities
a terrible match of incompetence with
brutality
this is a cruel reality and a dreadful
prospect
madam president
the more russia struggles in front of
ukraine's resistance the more kremlin's
rhetoric continues to escalate into the
mad man's idea of nuclear war
nuclear cyber rattling is inyominus
once it was the president himself then
another official and then the
unstoppable propaganda machine
what is the purpose of showing in the tv
a nuclear weapon
that could trigger a tsunami strong
enough to flood the entire uk
what is the logic of staging a nuclear
explosion in the heart of ireland
there could not be a more striking
contrast between dreams and projects of
science for conquering space and
extending human civilization beyond the
planet and this archaic and rotted
rhetoric of the possible use of weapons
of mass destruction of any
an annihilation of civilization
because of the war of choice that is
being
lost leon trotsky has written and i
quote
the army is a copy of society and
suffers from all its diseases usually at
a higher temperature
this is why truth is critical so that
the domestic and international opinion
does not fall for the propaganda and the
conspiracy theories
vacated really relentlessly from a black
hole from where only dark darkness is
escaping
only yesterday we celebrated world press
freedom day and i'd like to pay tribute
to all the brave journalists that are
risking their lives to tell the truth to
keep the world informed about the war in
ukraine
russian citizens must learn that this
war is not glorifying their country
it has isolated it like never before
it is not making it more prosper to the
country it is virtiginously spelling it
down
it is not transporting it to modernity
but rather dragging it into a revolved
past
no one wants to destroy russia
no one wants to cancel russia
if kremlin has made bad choices and
taken wrong decisions they can correct
the course which means stop the war
recall troops back home choose reason
return to diplomacy respect their
neighbor and let that big ukraine heart
beat in freedom as miss luzen mentioned
this is what is needed
the key word here is mir
madam president
after several failed attempts safe
passage was arduously secured for a
number of civilians in maripool mario
paul steele facility
which as we heard are underway this is a
testimony a welcome but a meager one
comparing the scale of tragedy in
ukraine that diplomacy vocal or silence
can work but there must be a will
those lucky ones that would see the sun
again after weeks in the underground to
escape relentless shelling
tell that before being escorted to
non-occupied parts of ukraine they had
been interrogated by
fsb agents seeking information on the
tunnels of
steel complex with a view to locating
ukrainian soldiers still in that
only part of mario paul not occupied by
the russian forces
unoccupied means destroyed
only two months ago mario paul was a
thriving city with almost half a million
inhabitants
the scorched earth strategy applied by
russia has made it the catacomb of
ukraine
madam president we know now the the main
mantra of the pretext of the war was
invasion of ukraine is to denasify the
country
despite the fact that the first citizen
the president of ukraine is jewish
yet the theory has been further
elaborated
pretending that the most ardent
anti-semites are usually jews that
hitler had jewish blood which underlines
the theory that jews inflicted the
holocaust to themselves just like the
ukrainians are supposedly slaughtering
their people and destroying their own
country
this is not black humor this is not one
of those basic fake news you easily
discard as rubbish
this is part of the worst conspiracy
theory warfare
and when you have the top diplomat dwell
on such disgracefulness
this is a terrible law coming from a
very dangerous high
madam president we are not in the
business of competition who speaks more
or louder we are here to try to stop
this war to stop those crimes protect
civilians and to make sure that the
perpetrators do not have a place in our
world but only in theirs the one where
they pay for their deeds through
accountability
we welcome the huge efforts of the
european union to respond to the massive
increase in humanitarian needs in
providing military financial and support
and other support for the reconstruction
we welcome the high-level international
donors conference for ukraine held today
in warsaw and albania made a commitment
duke partly made a commitment there
madam president
the secretary general
as we heard was received in moscow for
uneasy talks with authorities he also
visited kiev
as appalling and as shameful it may be
cave was shelled during his visit and
while he was speaking
rarely have we witnessed such a degree
of disregard for the u.n and its
secretary general such contempt for the
organization and the entire person you
and personal
i don't know how the russians explain
this unless in the very same way as for
everything else the ukrainians did it
let me end with this note
we should strongly reject any idea of
territorial division of ukraine imposed
by force as a result of aggression
we have mentioned it before and we
reiterate it now the creation of
artificial entities either by occupation
or by proxies is unacceptable
that should not be accepted in ukraine
or anywhere else and i thank you
i thank the representative
of albania for your statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of mexico
thank you very much madam president
united kingdom or its presidency
recognizing the efforts of the secretary
general
during his recent mission to russia and
ukraine
which is
the evacuation of a considerable number
of civilians that found themselves in
extremely critical conditions
the international committee of the red
cross
a
for the ukrainian civilian population
and whose repercussions at a global
level are beginning to
already have a harsh impact
while a cessation of hostilities
is made towards a diplomatic solution
the objective
that have been shared with us with
regard to the numbers of victims and the
harm and the cost caused by this
conflict
is that it is likely that the real
figures will be even greater
one year ago
unanimously adopted resolution 2573.
this resolution falls on all parties to
armed conflicts
fully abide by their obligations under
international
humanitarian law
once again we reiterate the obligation
to distinguish between
civilian populations and civilian
property on the one hand and combatants
and military targets on the other
no is permissible it is
and growing humanitarian needs
new mexico will follow closely the
developments on the investigation
announced by the prosecutor of the
international criminal court on the
situation in ukraine he
such investigations are fundamental
not least because international law is
the foundation of this organization
as it is also of multilateralism and
[Music]
and from the various treaties and other
sources of international law
and in particular
international human rights law
and international humanitarian law
senora president madam president
based on international
calling for an immediate cessation of
hostilities
because this is
the highest of all parties
following closely the ordinances of the
international court of justice
my delegation will continue encouraging
everything that enables unhindered
access for humanitarian assistance
and we
insist on the overwhelming need for the
security council
overcome
the paralysis that has held hostage
and to restore peace in ukraine
thank you very much
i thank the representative of mexico for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of france
madame president madam president
i wish to
thank the secretary general
agencies as well as humanitarian actors
resulted in the evacuation of hundreds
of civilians we are grateful for them
however how many more are still there
foreign
uh
federation
for more than two months the russian
army has been killing
including children
civilians
there is an urgent need for humanitarian
access to be provided to mariopol and
all the skills
at a time when more than 15 million
people need assistance
france will continue to fully contribute
we delivered more than 815
emergency assistance were delivered by
the european union
overall support will continue to
increase and reach
food
accountability
and international jurisdictions and
mechanisms including particularly the
international criminal courts they wish
to reiterate
thank you
i thank the representative of france for
their statement i give the floor to the
representative of china
thank you madame president
thank you
first of all thank you
terrorist and
ukraine has been reaching out
to promote cease-fire
so as to achieve a ceasefire as soon as
possible
to mitigate government situations
and thanks to the intensified
coordination between the uan and the
rcrc russia and ukraine have
agreed to a branch for the evacuation of
the civilians
and more than 300 civilians have been
successfully
this positive progress that was made
possible through consultations amongst
the rotten practice and thanks to the
search general for his instrumentals
to exercise maximum restraint avoid
hurting innocent civilians and civilian
facilities and give priority to ensuring
the humanitarian relief and assistance
building on
should continue to mobilize the
international community to increase
resource inputs
and its native countries to cope with
the pressure of the minister relief
spare new effort to save lives alleviate
people's sufferings and create
conditions for the safe and northerly
return of refugees to their homes
madame president
and the conflict has no winners dialogue
and negotiation is the only and
inevitable way to resolve disputes
russia and ukraine have built some
groundwork into previous negotiations
and more reason for them to continue
talks against
the international community should
create enabling conditions for the
russia ukraine negotiations and do more
things to facilitate the political
settlement rather than the other
it is not only morally despicable to try
and benefit from the turmoil but also
dangerous in reality the way doing so is
doomed to
backfire
continued
prices
foreign economy and international
relations we call on the international
community to strengthen macroeconomic
policy coordination and work together to
effectively
regulate and contain the negative
spiritual effects of the ukraine and
conflict
[Music]
security of all countries is indivisible
with debate one country is the security
and the insecurity of other countries
is neither reasonable
repeated eastward expansion afterwards
not only failed to make europe
safer but also sold the seats of
conflict
to its claim to be an organization
defensively
later wantonly launches
the chinese
to the perpetrators themselves and
deserve nothing less than china's
the world does not
together
i thank the representative of china for
their statement i give the floor now to
the representative of ghana
thank you very much madame president
let me begin by congratulating you
on your assumption of the presidency of
the council for the month of may
and to wish you the best of success
during the month
i also take this opportunity to thank
ambassador barbara woodward
and the uk delegation for the iabo
leadership of the council last month
we thank the secretary general for his
statement
and i've paid close attention to the
important briefings by the usg
martin griffiths
and mother mitchell
bachelet
the united nations high commissioner for
human rights
and thank them also for the accord
nation of the united nations efforts and
actions
in ukraine
we also thank mr tatiana luzan
for highlighting the work of her
organization in the area of protection
assistance
madam president
it is the ordinary people of ukraine who
continue to bear the brunt of the war
with women children and the aged being
disproportionately affected
urgent action is therefore imperative to
stem the rising humanitarian crisis
and restore the hope of peace
which has so far eluded the people of
ukraine
we therefore welcome the important
undertakings of the secretary general
during his recent visit to moscow and
kiev
where he held discussions with president
putin and preston zielinski
personally assessed the impact of the
war
and helped to mobilize humanitarian
evacuations in maripo
we encourage the continued deployment of
the good offices of the secretary
general
in the international endeavor to bring
an end to the war
and facilitate a diplomatic solution to
the ongoing security and humanitarian
crisis in ukraine
we commend the facilitative role played
by the united nations and the
international red cross
in the coordinated evacuation of
civilians from the azor style steel
plant on third may 2022
we have our regret the resumption of
heavy shelling
and airstrikes aimed at the steel plant
before all the people could be removed
to safety
intense efforts
must be made to secure the immediate
evacuation of close to thousand people
including an estimated number of thirty
children still hold up in the
underground tunnels of the steel plant
and little access to food water and
medical
assistance we urge the parties to agree
to further humanitarian pauses and
demilitarize humanitarian corridors
in all besieged areas to help protect
the lives of civilians
and ensure unobstructed delivery of
humanitarian aid to alleviate suffering
we note the set obligation of the
parties to conduct themselves in
accordance with the rules of
international law
and international humanitarian law
and reiterate our call on them to
implement necessary measures to protect
civilians and humanitarian workers from
harm
while also avoiding the deliberate
destruction of civilian and critical
infrastructure
including in leave
hackift
odessa and the donbass region where
intense fighting continues to reach
we continue also to be concerned by the
growing reports of gross human rights
violations and possible war crimes
involving ham summary killings forced
disappearances
human trafficking and conflict-related
sexual violence
and reiterate the necessity of an
independent impartial and tour
investigations to ensure effective
accountability and secure justice
for the innocent victims of the war
we welcome in this regard the
investigations opened into all cases of
alleged atrocities
madame president beyond the destruction
and humanitarian crisis in ukraine
the impact of the war is already being
felt on the food energy and financial
systems of the world
the direct disruptions in food supply
chains
and the high cost of energy have caused
historical rises
in cost of living globally
the stifling economic effects along with
the existing difficulties of the covet
19 pandemic
have the potential to fester social
political tensions and instability
especially in developing economies that
have little fiscal space to contain the
shocks
ending the war in ukraine is therefore
not only urgent to avoid a direct
humanitarian crisis for the ukrainian
people
but also critical to abate a global
meltdown
which would linger
and have deep adverse impacts on the
global economy the security architecture
and the multilateral order
furthermore we are concerned that our
vat commitments of their parties to
engage in negotiations
has so far not to you that the desired
results
due to grey mistrust and widening
differences in expectations
we encourage the parties to recommit to
the objectives of peace
and the settlement of their disputes
the international community and the
security council in particular must in
this context
overcome inherent challenges to
facilitate a constructive dialogue
first
to support the immediate and
unconditional cessation of hostilities
and second to provide a forum within
which the core geopolitical and security
concerns
of the russian federation ukraine and
and nato and its allied countries can be
sustainably addressed
in closing madam president we call on
the members of this council to find
common purpose
in working to restore and maintain the
peace and security of ukraine i thank
you for your kind attention
i thank the representative of ghana for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of kenya
thank you madam president
congratulations on your assumption
of the presidency this month
i thank the secretary general for his
remarks and welcome welcome him back to
new york after his extensive and
important travels
i also thank the other briefers for
their presentations and that and the
work that they're doing every day
and welcome the participation of
ukraine's distinguished permanent
representative as well as
the deputy prime minister of poland
among other
speakers today
madam president the briefings we have
heard make it clear
that the war in ukraine caused by the
armed breach of the country's
territorial integrity by the russian
federation is causing extreme suffering
it is also sadly clear that sufficient
care is not being accorded by combatants
to the protection of civilians
after all the millions of civilians who
have fled their homes only did so
because they understood that their lives
and properties would be directly harmed
in the course of the conflict
we are gravely concerned by the latest
developments in mariopol izum
among other cities
the reports
from these cities reveal heavy artillery
shelling and air strikes that are
destroying civilian objects at scale
these acts constitute a violation of the
u.n charter international law and
international humanitarian law
kenya condemns the disproportionate use
of force
the use of human shields and the
exploitation of civilian suffering as a
tactic of war
as important as it is for the security
council to be clear in its condemnation
of those violating our shared values and
rules it is more urgent to stop the
present cycle of escalation
public statements by the combatants and
their allies
suggest that there is little respite
from violence that civilians in ukraine
can look forward to
instead weapons and soldiers are being
deployed in ever greater numbers the war
itself and its aims are being
communicated as existential
there are even repeated mentions of the
possible use of nuclear weapons being
made in the media
the increased battlefield engagements
combined with their propaganda
counterpart in the shaping of domestic
and international public opinion
plus the apocalyptic tone
may lead to a far more dangerous
escalation than is presently the case
with the result being even more
ukrainians being harmed
connected to the harm being done to the
civilians in ukraine is the harm that
the war is causing in other parts of the
world
the inability of ukraine to export its
harvests and fertilizers is directly
contributing to the emission of many
millions
and
serious harm is being caused to their
food security
this is particularly the case in
relatively poor
and food insecure countries in the
global south including those in africa
the unprecedented sanctions in response
to the war are also reshaping global
development food security and even
political stability
with every new mention of nuclear
weapons as part of the conflict
continuum
or promises of unseizing war until one
side is permanently disabled
global equity and debt markets will exit
riskier emerging market economies
and investors will delay or cancel the
investments that we all need to deliver
sufficient jobs to our young people
madam president it is therefore our
contention
that the civilians in ukraine
while under the more immediate threat of
extreme violence
are united in their interest for safety
with the billions of other civilians
globally
it means that the whole world has a
stake in an immediate cessation of
hostilities for humanitarian purposes
followed by a structured ceasefire that
enables meaningful negotiations between
ukraine and the russian federation
in addition
if we want the global markets to play a
part in the development of the global
south
rather than the reverse
then europe's security order must be
placed on a stable footing
added to the growing global economic
crisis
that stable security order in europe is
also needed if we are to limit the harm
to civilians from climate change
the present array of
major geopolitical forces in a growing
conflict will make it next to impossible
to undertake ambitious climate change
action
even before this war started agreement
on climate adaptation and mitigation
action was plagued by lack of trust
changing goal posts and unmet
commitments
if climate change is indeed
as the science informs us
leading to serious harms to humanity
then we can count this war
and its deleterious impact on
multilateralism as yet another worldwide
blow to the safety and security of
civilians worldwide
madam president
the multilateral system at this rate
may not survive the multiple major
crises we are causing while undermining
its ability to solve them
as a minimum response to protecting the
peace kenya urges member states to place
more trust in the good offices of the
secretary general
the historical record
of the use of these good offices is
replete with shortcomings
but also with great successes
the decisive factor has been the extent
to which conflicting states
and their most influential allies give
the secretary general space to help
mediate conflict at all stages
we therefore welcome the secretary
general's recent trips to russia and
ukraine where he sought commitments for
ceasefire
safe humanitarian passage and to
encourage negotiations
we urge the parties to embrace his
readiness
to mediate
their doing so will signal their regard
and respect for our united nations
madam president i
in conclusion
that the continued undermining and even
destruction
of multilateralism will only lead to
more war
it will be a catastrophe for civilians
in multiple regions and countries
stopping the war in ukraine offers us
all an opportunity to live up to the
charter's promise to protect succeeding
generations from our own shortcomings
i reaffirm kenya's respect for the
sovereignty territorial integrity and
political independence of ukraine with
its within its internationally
recognized borders i thank you for your
attention
i thank the representative of kenya for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of brazil
thank you very much madam president
madam president i would like to thank
the participation
of secretary general antonio guterres
high commission michelle bachelet
usg martin griffiths
and mr tiana luzon
as well as their first hound accounts
from the conflict in ukraine
the brazilian government continues to
follow closely the ongoing conflict in
ukraine
our utmost priorities should be
the immediate cessation of hostilities
and the strengthening of diplomatic
negotiations
in order to bring a lasting solution to
this crisis
one that does not only end the conflict
but also contributes to improve the
security and defense architecture in
europe further than the human rights
violations and the humanitarian costs of
the conflict
we are also attentive to the negative
economic effects of the war for the
whole world
especially in the form of higher food
and energy prices
which have particularly dire
consequences
for developing countries
we acknowledge the efforts of the
secretary general in his recent visits
to moscow and cave to discuss with
presidents putin and zelensky how to
establish safe humanitarian corridors to
allow the evacuation of civilians from
conflagrated areas such as in the city
of mariopol
we commend all the tireless work being
done by the united nations and the
international committee of the red cross
to provide humanitarian aid to millions
of people inside ukraine
being cognizant that the needs of
humanitarian assistance remain huge
we would also like to express our
appreciation to the neighboring
countries of ukraine for keeping their
borders open to refugees
i would also like to express my
recognition
to the secretary general
for having raised this afternoon
despite not being the central focus of
this meeting
the impact that the conflict
and its associated factors
are having on food security worldwide
brazil stresses the importance of all
parties in the conflict to fully respect
international humanitarian law
especially in its provisions
regarding the protection of civilians
of particular concern to brazil are
first
the consequences of shelling of urban
areas including with the use of
explosive weapons and the targeting of
civilians
second
the need to avoid the destruction of
civilian infrastructure and the
disruption of basic services
third
the protection of the elderly people
with disabilities and children among
other vulnerable groups
fourth
the protection of humanitarian personnel
and unimpeded humanitarian access
and fifth
the protection of refugees and
internally displaced persons
it is our belief that the humanitarian
resolution adopted by the general
assembly last march
provides an adequate framework for
concrete actions on the ground
as guaranteeing safe passage for
civilians and unimpeded access for
humanitarian personnel
furthermore resolution a stroke rare
stroke es11 stroke 2
provides us with the main objectives we
should strive to achieve
in particular the full compliance by all
parties to the armed conflict to respect
international humanitarian law
international human rights law
and international refugee law
within its capabilities brazil is
contributing to the humanitarian efforts
offering shelter to citizens fleeing the
armed conflict in ukraine
since last march brazil has granted
temporary visas and residency
authorization for ukrainian nationals
and stateless persons who have been
affected or displaced by the events in
ukraine
brazil has also donated food medicine
and water purifiers to the victims of
the conflict
madam president the lives and well-being
of civilians in conflagrated areas
are in great jeopardy
the cessation of hostilities is a matter
of urgency
we have already witnessed too much
suffering
the effective delivery of humanitarian
aid is of paramount importance
moreover we need a resumption of
diplomatic negotiations that are
conducive to a peaceful and lasting
solution to this crisis i thank you
i thank the representative of brazil for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of ireland
thank you very much madam president and
i'd like to welcome back the secretary
general and thank him for his briefing
this afternoon and also to extend a
particularly warm welcome to michelle
bachelet high commissioner bachelet and
also thanks to under secretary general
griffiths and a big thank you to tatiana
luzan
for updating us today uh both of you on
the humanitarian disaster in ukraine
excuse me
your briefings
highlight yet again
the sheer the utter senselessness of
this unlawful war
madam president
11 weeks into this unjustified
unjustifiable war
we continue to witness widespread
destruction indiscriminate attacks and
unconscionable human suffering
as each day passes reports of violations
of human rights and international
humanitarian law by russia grow
and as we've heard from colleagues
around this table the consequences are
being felt far beyond ukraine and europe
russia must end its war now
we salute the courageous decision by the
secretary general to visit moscow and
kiev last week
the founders of these united nations
were clear on their primary objective
to prevent the human suffering
wrought from war
the secretary general speaks for all of
us in deploring this war and calling for
its end
the cynical timing of further attacks on
civilian infrastructure during your time
in kiev secretary general and following
your visit to moscow is further evidence
of the disdain that has been shown
towards the u.n
it is more than regrettable
that we should have to recall that the
secretary general of the un is appointed
by all members of the un
he is mandated by all members of the un
we have a responsibility towards our
secretary general
secretary general what you witnessed in
bucha in urban
borodianca
follows the devastation wrought on
kharkiv kersen and mario paul as well as
elsewhere
civilians as you said are paying the
highest price for this conflict
we commend the work of the un agencies
in ukraine and the organizations with
whom they are working to alleviate the
suffering there
they have our support they have our
appreciation we welcome your work to put
in place arrangements for the evacuation
of civilians from mariopol
we welcome
the ongoing life-saving work of the un
and the icrc there
we believe that thousands still remain
trapped and under siege
we encourage all parties to ensure that
these safe passage operations continue
and that humanitarian aid reach all
those in need
parties to the conflict must comply with
international humanitarian law including
the obligation to limit attacks to
military objects
that also includes the prohibitions
against indiscriminate and
disproportionate attacks
and the obligation to take all feasible
precautions in attack
compliance is not optional
madam president we have heard today from
high commissioner bachelet of how
civilians continue to bear the brunt of
this unconscionable war
we condemn the horrific violations
documented by the un human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine
unlawful killings including summary
executions
conflict-related sexual violence
arbitrary detentions and deportations
including of journalists human rights
defenders and civil society activists
enforced disappearances
and torture of prisoners of war
all allegations of violations of
international human rights and
humanitarian law must continue to be
investigated
and those responsible held to account
the people of ukraine deserve nothing
less
let's be clear madam president daily we
see the devastating impact of the use of
explosive weapons including prohibited
cluster munitions by russian forces in
populated areas without regard for
civilians
we see the toll of destruction of homes
hospitals and schools
we know what we're dealing with
it cannot be dismissed as fake news
the sheer scale of destruction in itself
belies the russian federation's attempt
to dissemble and distort reality
we condem indiscriminate and
disproportionate attacks in all
circumstances
we reject all efforts to question
reality
we are resolved to ensuring
accountability for the atrocious crimes
taking place in ukraine
we recognize the important role of the
ongoing investigation of the
international criminal court in helping
to pursue
this we must not
we cannot accept impunity for those
inflicting such horrors not in ukraine
not anywhere else in the world
as you said last week high commissioner
accountability is a cornerstone of
upholding human rights
we will never shirk our responsibility
in upholding human rights
we once again call on the russian
federation to comply with its
obligations under international law
to allow full safe and unhindered
humanitarian access for humanitarian
personnel
to allow all those seeking to leave
ukraine to do so safely
and to destinations of their choosing
civilians who choose to remain in
ukraine
are not combatants
that is a fact pure and simple
they must be protected in accordance
with international humanitarian law
madam president the international
community and this council must not
become numb to the devastation and
tragedy that continues in
ukraine i am marked by the horror of the
death of a 91 year old holocaust
survivor who froze to death in a
basement in mariopol
her life ending under our watch
in a shameful reflection of how as a
child she had hidden to save her own
life
during the war she called the great
patriotic war
stopping this war today could not undo
what has been done it could not bring
back those lost
nor raise the horrors that those who
have been forced to flee have endured
it could not undo the human suffering
already caused around the world
but it would stop the slaughter
it would save lives
russia must end its aggression comply
with its obligations under international
law and withdraw all forces
unconditionally from the entirety of the
sovereign territory of ukraine
we call again on the russian federation
to end its war
it is never too late to do the right
thing
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of ireland
for their statement i give the floor to
the representative of the russian
federation
madam president
first and foremost we wish to
congratulate the united states
[Music]
the accession to the presidency of the
security council for the month of may
we trust
you that's uh unlike the previous
presidency
yours will be
effective
we have a number of questions that arose
in connection to that however i wish to
recall
for both colleagues and the high
commissioner
according to general assembly resolution
101 which established 141 which
established the mandate of that
commissioner this official
is under the aegis of the secretary
general
and thereby bears the main
responsibility for united nations human
rights action within the framework of
the overall authority
[Music]
or protection of civilians you you are
competent
under their purview
madam president what is it
now we have been discussing the
developments in ukraine
and for two months
the flow of hostility lies deceit faith
hatred and insults
we have heard the same old questions
[Music]
did not pose any threat to russia itself
i allow that they're made though
those who may not understand what
actually took place foreign
who have long dreamed of transforming
ukraine into a bridgehead for
a battle against russia yeah
independence 30 years ago but he teaches
politically
ideologically
and today they continue to do this by
flooding weapons into ukraine
you and they continue to tell you what
you want to hear
we have listened to them and we continue
to listen to them in the original
without translation we have no one and
we continue to know about their
machinations
intractability
completely
not just at the everyday level but also
at the level of government officials and
public figures
third ukrainian school history
books an entire generation of people who
have been
reared with the hatred of russia
has become the main domestic national
product for the ukrainian officials
anything of the sort with respect to
ukraine or ukrainian people
simply don't hear theirs
[Music]
despite the fact that the murders were
well known
nationalism which thrives
this is a proxy war of the collective
west again
level today
for a long time well before
we simply are basically more rating in
the finest traditions
if anybody here is unaware
of
the countless sanctions and bad
accounts belonging to russia amounting
to 300 billion dollars
what kind of international law are you
talking about
rules-based order which you conceived
on its colonies
looting their national resources along
the way
this is nothing other than the
the most basic lawlessness and plunder
the masks have been cast off
however it has now become trendy to
accuse of russia of the energy for the
energy and the food crisis which you
yourselves have created
describe to you the suffering of the
people in danville we describe the
shelling by the ukrainian armed forces
and the nationalist battalions
i give it
[Music]
complete ukrainization of the madonna
authorities you did not respond
you do not wish to recall
2014.
we're brutally dispersing
and that's very
was needed
[Music]
under the illusion that they would enjoy
complete impunity
bankrupt ukraine are the bankrupt
ukrainian authorities deeply regretful
of what it is now
all of the crimes perpetrated by the key
of regimes
special military operation began to
liberate
now we suddenly heard desperate pleas
what have we done wrong
are knowledgeable in ukrainian russian
folklore will understand what i'm
talking about
and not even
you did not take them
yourself
of the purely defensive nature
moving the borders
arrogantly okay
and there's no need to persuade us today
your plans never included an attempt uh
the desire to bring up
that was the case
ukraine was necessary to the west only
as an arena foreign
is already waging a proxy war again
to be shocked continuously
uh partners the theme and the question
of the issue of the progression of the
us and the west in iraq
syria
it is as if it is improper to recall
these
there was a struggle there against
is comprised of former iran
so who's the real sponsor of terrorism
we are living in a state of information
more accurately disinformation
psychological operations which have been
deployed on the information
the objective is not only true yeah
ukrainian people
the long-standing artillery barrage
company
now this has been
reversed
is the international community doesn't
need to hear anything about ukraine
foreign
at homes and kindergartens and hospitals
and and and the flats civilization
residence is the
they are often shot in the back by their
by the way
there are troves of evidence about this
you just don't want to hear it
prisoners of war images
against ukrainian prisoners
from those cities
the ukrainian nationalist conduct and
actions
themselves
i cannot butt note
i cannot know the secretary
russia the russian side has regularly
been opening humanitarian
civilians
a desire to return to liberated
as of style in exchange for every all
every group of 15 liberated hostages for
them to be provided with one ton of
foodstuffs and medicine
only is
who said that the army is a copy of
society
is this episode what you were talking
about
tomorrow we will hold a meeting on
ukraine's violations of international
humanitarian law
and aria foreign
information thank you
in my role as president of the security
council i thank the representative of
russia for his statement i now give the
floor to the representative of the
united arab emirates
madam president at the outset let me
thank ambassador barbara woodward and
the delegation of the united kingdom for
their able stewardship of the security
council in april and i wish the united
states success and offer our full
support for its presidency this month
i'd like to thank the secretary general
for his briefing and updates on his
visit to russia and ukraine as well as
for his exercise of his good offices in
this conflict we fully support his
continued effort and engagement
thanks also to under secretary general
griffiths and high commissioner bachelet
and ms luzon for their briefings
as the secretary general noted last week
civilians always pay the highest price
in war
as the conflict moves into its third
months its repercussions have far
exceeded many worst case projections
made at the start of hostilities in
february
unhcr now believes that more than 8
million ukrainians could end up fleeing
the country double the initial estimates
at the same time undp forecasts that the
war will soon erase nearly two decades
of progress in the development of
ukraine
and we have not yet fully absorbed how
the impact of this war is reverberating
globally though there are clearly
already repercussions being felt through
rising commodity prices and supply
disruptions as well as disruptions to
the global financial system on which we
are all dependent for shared stability
and development
we remain deeply concerned by reports of
rising civilian casualties and the
ongoing destruction of civilian
infrastructure
it is imperative to underline once again
that all parties must abide by their
obligations under international human
rights law and international
humanitarian law
this necessarily includes respect for
the fundamental international
humanitarian law principles of necessity
proportionality and distinction
the council has built a framework to
strengthen the protection of civilians
and civilian objects including its
unanimous adoption of resolution 2573
just over a year ago
attacks on civilian infrastructure can
undermine the provision of essential
services to the civilian population and
have horrifying knock-on effects
we appreciate the efforts of
international actors to provide tools
and mechanisms to operationalize this
framework and we call on the parties to
engage in the design of urgently needed
solutions including for safe and
voluntary passage
we are encouraged by the recent progress
regarding safe passage from moriopol
through coordinated action by the un the
authorities of both ukraine and the
russian federation and the international
committee of the red cross and we're
hopeful that it can be built upon
however as we've underscored before
initiatives like corridors do not alter
the obligations of the parties to uphold
international humanitarian law
the secretary general's proposal of a
contact group is a welcome starting
point to implement additional measures
supporting ihl implementation and we
hope to hear more details about the
proposal in the near future
as the conflict continues we join others
in emphasizing the critical importance
of increased humanitarian assistance to
ukraine and to the neighboring countries
hosting refugees as part of our ongoing
support the uae most recently dispatched
a plane on the 28th of april carrying 30
additional tons of food supplies
supporting refugees from ukraine and
moldova and we're committed to continue
working with international partners on
relief efforts
we emphasize too the need to
systematically take into account needs
based on gender age and disability and
provided humanitarian assistance not
least as it also supports longer term
recovery efforts
finally we reiterate that the protection
of civilians can only be assured with a
cessation of hostilities and a
diplomatic solution to this conflict
we call on both sides to remain
committed despite the difficulties to
direct dialogue and for the
international community and this council
to create the conditions to help halt
the war and ultimately bring about a
lasting peace in europe and stability to
our international order
the alternative
increasing polarization and the
resulting ruptures are in no country's
interest neither today or in the future
we must step back from this brink thank
you
i thank the representative of the united
arab emirates for her statement and i
now pass the floor to the representative
of gabon
i congratulate you madam president
[Music]
um
71 days
the daily life of those who have decided
to remain in their country more than 30
million people have been forced into
displacement including 5.5 million
people who have been forced to leave
ukraine since the outbreak of war on the
24th of february
numerous towns and cities around the
country are almost entirely destroyed
including transportation routes for
instance
in the distribution energy gas drinking
water production and distribution
facilities
must ever be targeted
is
is
humanitarian emergencies
indeed the price of food
fuels and energy resources are already
reaching unprecedented highs and we are
all on a personal level
collateral victims
escalating
is hardening on the ground we see
increasing flows of weapons and um
is
ukrainian people thank you
i thank the representative of gabon for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of the united
kingdom
thank you madam president and before i
start may i thank you and others for
your kind words uh towards me and my
team and wish you a successful
presidency
on this subject i would like to start by
thanking the briefers for their
statements and i welcome the secretary
general's participation in this meeting
on the 4th of april
the russian permanent representative
told the un press corps
that what was happening in ukraine was
warfare
and that
in warfare you cannot exclude that
civilians are dying
the truth is
that it's not just that civilians are
dying in russia's illegal war of
aggression
but that russia
is deliberately waging a war designed to
terrorize and kill ukrainian people
civilians have been executed and
dismembered in butcher and european
distinction has been drawn
between military targets
hospitals schools
or the mariupol theatre outside which
children was clearly written
and where the latest reporting suggests
that as many as 600 people were killed
russia's actions are clear violations
of international humanitarian law
including
but not limited to resolutions 22 86
24 17
and 25 73
madam president
i'd like to make three points
on the issue of protection of civilians
in ukraine
the first and clearest solution
to end the suffering of civilians
is for russia to end its illegal war
and withdraw its troops from ukraine
unless it does so
civilians will continue to die
and many millions more will be put at
risk
across the globe
due to food and energy shortages
resulting from the invasion
this is what the secretary general
referred to as
the limitless potential for global harm
second
while the invasion continues
international humanitarian law must be
strictly observed
and full humanitarian access to
civilians facilitated
we commend the secretary general and his
team for the efforts that led to the
evacuation to safety of about 500
civilians from the azov style works
but it should be a matter of profound
concern for this council
that humanitarian supplies were not
allowed into the city
and that the shelling of the steel works
restarted immediately
third
we're deeply concerned
that russia's war
is accompanied
by a propaganda campaign
including in this council
designed to dehumanize and demonize
ukrainians
by labeling them as neo-nazis
this hate speech
is extremely dangerous
and
as we near the anniversary of the end of
world war ii
it disrespects the sacrifices
of those russians ukrainians and many
other nationalities
who fought to end nazism
finally madam president i want to assure
you that the uk continues its help and
support to ukraine
and today we announced a further 45
million pounds
for humanitarian and un organizations to
support the vulnerable and provide
medical equipment
i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her statement and i now pass
the floor to the representative of
norway
thank you president
let me thank usg griffiths high
commissioner barceley and tatiana lusan
for your brief for your sobering but
very important insight into the daily
reality of millions of ukrainians
with a special thanks to the secretary
general for his briefing and for his
recent visit to russia and ukraine
you have our strong support to use your
good offices in search for a peaceful
solution to this senseless horrific war
in ukraine
norway recalls that all member states
under the charter of the united nations
have the obligation to settle their
international disputes by peaceful means
we support all sincere efforts towards
political dialogue
negotiations and mediation
but
it is russia that has chosen to start an
unprovoked war of aggression against
ukraine and must take steps to end it
president
we welcome yesterday's joint statement
by a cross-regional group of freedom of
expression mandate holders
we agree that it is precisely during
times of war and armed conflict that the
right to freedom of expression and free
access to information must be vigorously
defended
it is instrumental for the promotion of
lasting peace understanding the causes
of conflict and ensuring accountability
president we continue to be alarmed by
the humanitarian situation including in
mario pool
as u high commissioner barceley have
highlighted
it seems that
international humanitarian law has not
merely been ignored but seemingly tossed
aside
safe rapid and unimpeded humanitarian
access to people in need must be
allowed immediately
while we are relieved that the safe
passage operation to evacuate civilians
from the avocad steel plant was
successful in bringing some to safety
the poor condition of many of the
evacuees shows the urgent need to allow
for the humanitarian voluntary safe
passage of thousands of civilians and
hundreds of wounded wounded out of the
city
norway is deeply worried that russia's
intensified hostilities in eastern
ukraine will lead to new besiegement of
entire cities and towns
and that the suffering and bloodshed
that that has engulfed mario pool may be
repeated elsewhere
we call on russia to immediately end
these
relentless attacks on civilians the
continued bombardment of civilian
infrastructure must also stop
ukrainian ports must be reopened to
allow wheat and grain to reach those in
need globally
the crippling impact of russia's war on
the food security of millions is
unacceptable
president there are abundant indication
of massive scale war crimes being
committed
these atrocities will not be forgotten
individuals at all levels will be held
to account
there must be accountability for the
sake of the victims and all people of
ukraine
we welcome the international criminal
court and the commission of inquiry on
ukraine
will continue
to coordinate
cooperate and work together with others
to investigate possible violation of
human rights and international
humanitarian law
also earlier this week the un signed a
framework of cooperation with ukraine on
the prevention and respond to
conflict-related sexual violence
this is key this is a key example of
positive partnership that the secretary
general's good offices can provide
we strongly support all efforts made to
bolster accountability risk mitigation
against trafficking and access to
comprehensive services for survivors
president i started my remarks today
reminding of the obligation of member
states to settle their dispute through
peaceful means
russia started this senseless war russia
must immediately completely and
unconditionally withdraw all its
military forces from the territory of
ukraine within its international
recognized border i thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
their statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of india
thank you
madam president
allow me at the outset to thank the
united kingdom
for a successful presidency
i wish the united states all success in
their presidency
let me thank secretary general antonio
gutierrez for his presence and remarks
on the situation in ukraine
i thank high commissioner for human
rights michelle bachelet and usg martin
griffiths for their updates
i also thank miss tatiana luzan for her
insights
ever since the commencement of the
conflict in ukraine
india has been consistently calling for
complete secession of hostilities
and for pursuing the path of dialogue
and diplomacy as the only way out
however the conflict has resulted in the
laws of lives and countless miseries for
its people
especially for women children and
elderly
with millions becoming homeless and
forced to take shelter in neighbouring
countries
india has strongly condemned killing of
civilians in bhusha and supported the
call for an independent investigation
we support all efforts to alleviate the
suffering of the people of ukraine
india remains on the side of peace and
therefore believes that there will be no
winning side in this conflict and while
those impacted by this conflict will
continue to suffer diplomacy will be a
lasting casualty
we welcome the visit of the secretary
general to moscow and kiev and his
engagement with the leadership of the
russian federation and ukraine
we agree that the immediate
is of evacuation of innocent civilians
from areas witnessing intense fighting
we deeply appreciate the efforts of the
united nations in evacuating civilian
population from mario pole
we hope these efforts will extend to
other areas as well
the conflict is having destabilizing
effect with broader regional and global
implications
oil prices are skyrocketing and there is
shortage of food grains and fertilizers
this has had disproportionate impact on
the global south and developing
countries
we acknowledge the efforts made by the
secretary general particularly the
findings of global crisis response group
task team
we welcome the recommendation for
exempting purchases of food for
humanitarian assistance by wfp
from food export restrictions with
immediate effect
it is important that similar such
exemptions are provided to all member
states and relevant stakeholders who are
contributing to this global humanitarian
effort
the food security challenges emanating
from the conflict require us to respond
by going beyond constraints that bind us
presently
energy security is equally serious
as a concern and needs to be addressed
through cooperative efforts
india has been sending humanitarian
supplies to ukraine and its neighbors we
are also providing more medical supplies
to ukraine
we support calls for guarantees of safe
passage to deliver essential
humanitarian and medical supplies
including through establishment of
humanitarian corridors
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively to the
evolving humanitarian requirements
we reiterate the importance of human
guiding principles of humanitarian
assistance humanitarian action must
always be guided by the principles of
humanitarian assistance which is
humanity neutrality impartiality and
independence
these measures
should never be politicized let me
conclude by reaffirming that the
contemporary global order has been built
on the u.n charter international law and
respect for sovereignty and territorial
integrity of states i thank you
the representative of india for their
statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as representative
of the united states
first let me sincerely thank the
secretary general for his remarks and
for his update from the region
i'm so glad that you've returned to us
safe and sound and i know that you must
be jet lagged after
your trip practically around the world
but your being here
shows us the commitment that you have to
this institution
also thank you to under secretary
general griffiths and high commissioner
bachelet for your remarks
and thank you to our civil society
briefer
tatiana lazan for joining us at this
late hour for you
and for your powerful testimony here
today
i welcome the representative
from ukraine as well as his excellency
the deputy prime minister from poland
as well as other speakers who are here
with us today
colleagues there are no signs russia's
war against ukraine is abating
russia's forces may have abandoned their
attempt to capture keeve
but russia continues to conduct missile
strikes against kiev
and terrorize citizens across ukraine
independent media reports have laid out
a deadly pattern of attacks in the past
two weeks
on april 23rd reports indicate russia
russian missiles strikes kills civilians
in odessa
including
a three-month-old
a three-month-old girl
then russian missiles hit a thermal
power plant and all refinery in crimean
juke the next day
the day after that
russian forces attacked
five railway stations across ukraine
the following day
two rockets
flew dangerously close to a nuclear
plant posing colossal safety risk to the
region
this string of attacks culminated on
april 28th
when russia had the audacity
to attack kiev
while the secretary general
was there to discuss humanitarian aid
and peace
russia has violated the u.n charter
russia has ignored
our unified
global call
to end
this war
the message we continue to hear loud and
clear from moscow is that russia does
not respect
or believe in the u.n
our charter and will not be a
responsible actor in the international
system
over the past 10 weeks
just 10 weeks
we've seen russia continue to wage an
unprovoked war
against a smaller neighbor
we've seen russia
brutalize civilian populations and
attack thousands of civilian used
buildings structures and vehicles
apartment buildings schools
shopping malls markets cafes trams
heating plants grain silos food storage
facilities
hospitals orphanages
maternity ward
the list goes on
russia has lied to this council
repeatedly with a wild string of
conspiracy theories and disinformation
even falsehood more ridiculous than the
last
three months ago russian representatives
told this council they had no intention
to invade ukraine
now russia claims the attacks aren't
real
or never happened
russia has even claimed that ukraine is
attacking itself that they bomb their
own buildings
attacked their own people
and assaulted
their own democracy
these lies defy all logic
all evidence and common sense
russia is spreading pure disinformation
the truth is well known
russia is the only perpetrator of this
war
so it's hard to understand
while some council members continue to
call on all parties to desist
let's call a spade a spade
members should call on russia
explicitly to stop its aggression
against ukraine
we have imagery that confirms the
presence of mass graves in bucha
and this is not just an unverified
accusation on social media
it is a horrifying fact
one the world must now reckon with
russia alone started this war
and russia alone can end it
silence the guns
withdraw from ukrainian territory
and embrace diplomacy
recently the eyes of the world have been
trained on mariopol where hundreds of
civilians have been taking
shelter in a steel plant besieged by
russian forces
we all watched in horror as russia laid
siege
mercilessly against civilians trapped
inside and underground for weeks
this week the un
and president
zielinski announced that over a hundred
ukrainians have finally been rescued and
reached relative safety and we applaud
the un
and icrc's role in this rescue and we
strongly support the five convoys the
u.n has sent to besieged areas
but we're concerned that attacks on the
plant have reportedly resumed with
civilians still inside
and will be following the situation
closely
what we truly need is unhindered access
throughout ukraine so the un and its
partners can reach everyone in need
and people of all nationalities can flee
to safety
convoys and evacuations take days and
weeks or months of intense negotiation
they cannot be the norm
the only norm we should accept
is ukraine returning to its normal life
without russian forces illegally in its
territory terrorizing and killing
civilians including so many innocent
children
here in the security council and at the
united nations we can help ukraine
return to normancy
we can do that in two ways by supporting
the ukrainian people and their efforts
and by holding russia
accountable on the first point we must
address the immediate and dire
humanitarian situation both in ukraine
and outside of it
and for our part the united states
announced this morning at the pledging
conference in warsaw that we will
provide an additional
387 million dollars in humanitarian
assistance to ukraine
this brings the total we have committed
thus far to over
688 million dollars since russia's
further invasion
that money will help our brave partners
rapidly distribute food and clean
drinking water sanitation and hygiene
kits critical
medical supplies and even cash to those
who need it most in ukraine
we must also be equally attentive to the
way russia's war of choice is harming
countries beyond ukraine's borders
from the arrival of millions of refugees
to europe
to the global food crisis that is
hitting african and middle eastern
markets particularly hard
i suspect we will hear more details
about this from our colleagues who are
joining this meeting today
russia is actively halting
ukrainian agricultural production and
blocking the ports that once provided
food to those in dire need
while we work to stop this blockade and
hold russia to account for his actions
we will all be called to step up and
prevent looming famines and provide more
food and funding in the name of decency
and humanity
we will focus the attention of this
council on this and other aspects of
global food insecurity during the open
debate we will convene later this month
and second we must hold those in russia
who unleashed
perpetrated and ordered
the war crimes committed in ukraine to
account
the united states supports a range of
international investigations
into the atrocities in ukraine including
efforts by the international criminal
court
the united
for their lives
all of the values the u.n holds
stand with them
and with the overwhelming majority of
the international community
in defense of sovereignty of liberty and
democracy thank you
i now resume my function as president of
the council
i would like to again draw the attention
of speakers to paragraph 22
of note
507 which encourages all participants in
council meetings to deliver their
statements in five minutes or less
in line with the security council's
commitment to making more effective use
of open meetings
i now give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
you madam president
distinguished members of the council
i also recognize the
representative of putin's regime in the
permanent seat of the soviet union
at the outset let me express gratitude
to secretary general guterres
under secretary general griffith
high commissioner partially
and civil society representative tatiana
luzan for their briefings
i join all previous speakers in
expressing appreciation of a very
successful
presidency
of the council by the united kingdom
last week the secretary general visited
ukraine at a time when country continues
to defend
the very principles of the united
nations charter
it was important that antonia guterres
visited the suburbs of kiev and saw with
his own eyes
the horrific war crimes committed by
russia in ukraine
i'm grateful to the secretary general
for the clear and unequivocal position
on the war against ukraine
as a violation of territorial integrity
and the u.n charter
i appreciate the efforts to use the good
offices mechanisms
for the escalation
every opportunity must be used to
achieve peace
on behalf of the president of ukraine i
would like to thank the secretary
general the u.n team and the
international committee of the red cross
who demonstrated the possibility of
making progress and saving civilians
from mariupol which is blocked by the
russian army
and i quote
the whole world has learned about the
role of the un and the icrc
in this
this has shown the international
organizations can be effective
end of
quote the second stage of the evacuation
operation from mariupol was completed
344 people were rescued from the city
and its suburbs in addition to more than
150 people who were taken out of azov
style
there are still civilians
women children
therefore the evacuation operation must
be
continued madam president russia has
shelled almost 2 000 missiles on
ukrainian cities
most of them hate civilians
not military infrastructure
russia struggles to advance and suffers
terrible losses
this is the reason why they resort to
this desperate missile terror across
ukraine
they want to break us down but the only
thing
that will break break down in the end is
russia
and its capacity to invade bomb murder
loot and rape
here i would like to recall one of my
competitors
alexander mahoff
a well-known journalist in ukraine
born in the luhansk region
in 2017 he was the first ukrainian
journalist to visit our station in
antarctica
covet came
he was not afraid he lived in sanjari
where ukrainians were brought from china
for two weeks
from the first day of the full-scale war
he was on the front line
volunteer ato veteran
warrior of the 95th assault brigade
he was killed in the harkey region
in the battles near izum
he was 36 years old and my sincere
condolences to his family and friends
russia will be a responsibility for
these deaths
as well as for that of every hero who
gave their life for ukraine
ukraine is not afraid
and the world should not be afraid
either
russia's missile terrorism
must be punished
and responded to a stronger sanctions
and increased military assistance for
ukraine
madam president on the 1st of may the
russian ministry of war declared that
more than 1 million people have been
transferred to russia including
193 000 children
most of them in particular those
transferred from mariupol
undergo filtration camps with mandatory
procedures that constitute violations of
their human rights
being stripped naked
fingerprinting
interrogation
eyewitnesses testify that russian
soldiers kill those whom they consider
suspicious
there have been multiple reported cases
of kidnapping or taking hostage of
ukrainian civilians by russian troops
there are numerous cases of mistreatment
of forcefully displaced ukrainian
citizens in the russian federation
including depriving them of their
ukrainian passports and preventing them
from leaving russian territory
we reiterate that all ukrainian citizens
forcefully transferred by russia must be
granted safe return to the territory of
ukraine
madam president food security in ukraine
and worldwide worldwide appears to be
another deliberate target of russia
as of now russia has stolen about 400
000 tons of grain from the temporarily
occupied parts of zappoligia herzog
donetsk and lugansk regions
a third of all reserves in the regions
given that the stolen grain was to be
used before the next harvest it has
already increased the threat of famine
in addition to stealing grain russia
attacks grain silos
farming infrastructure and fertilizers
fertilizer stores
and continues to still farm vehicles
the looting of grain from the occupied
part of ukraine
the blockade of shipments from ukrainian
ports and the mining of shipping routes
and danger global food security
russia is in fact harming not only
ukraine but the world population
through its illegal actions
according to the united nations over 1.7
billion people may risk poverty and
famine as a result of disruptions in the
food production system caused by
russia's full-scale war against ukraine
furthermore russia continues
to intentionally block sowing in ukraine
we demand that russia stop illicit grain
theft unblock ukrainian ports restore
freedom of navigation and allow trade
ships to pass
we urge the international community to
strengthen economic sanctions against
russia in order to stop its military
aggression against ukraine to avert a
humanitarian disaster and the world's
food security crisis
madam president today the state of
israel
is celebrating the 74th anniversary of
its independence
on november 29
1947 ukraine as a member of the united
nations
voted in favor of the iran general
assembly resolution 181
the following year in may israel
declared its independence
taking this opportunity i wish peace and
prosperity to israel and all jews around
the world
as we are approaching may 9 the threat
of new provocations and the raising of
the stakes by russia is increasing
in this regard i would like to condemn
the anti-semitic attacks by the russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov on the
president of ukraine and all jews
such attacks are absolutely unacceptable
lavrov could not help revealing the
deep-rooted anti-semitism
of russia's elites
it demonstrates
to the world that putin's russia is
purposefully cultivating russian
supremacy
and hatred of other peoples
russia is already too deeply bogged down
in uttering nonsense aimed at justifying
his barbaric aggression against ukraine
in fact the russian foreign minister
questioned the existence of not only the
ukrainian nation but also the holocaust
lavrov deliberately insulted the memory
of millions of jews who died at the
hands of the nazis during world war ii
madam president at this point i would
like to bring your attention to one of
the latest examples
of russian atrocities in ukraine
on may 4 the bodies of two young men
aged 22 and 23
were exhumed in the village of rudnyat
tulska in kiev region
on the 25th of february the russian
invaders shot at a car
with them inside
it was not enough however for the
so-called russian soldiers to kill
innocent civilians they decided to run
over the car with heavy equipment
while the two men were inside
this is insane
this is inhumane
while we are in this meeting the russian
terrorists
terrorist practice of shelling ukrainian
cities throughout the entire country
with long-range missiles continues
the secretary general had a chance to
witness this practice last thursday
during his visit to kiev
there was no however strong reaction
from the security council on this
deliberate attack
in this regard in action of the security
council and its ability only to express
deep concerns continues to irritate the
international community
undermine its authority
in accordance with the enchanter and
create an atmosphere of impunity
as it appears this chamber
has turned from a venue of diplomatic
debates
into a biological hazard site
there is a trail of blood
and a sickening smell of smoldering
bodies
of women
men
and children
that a russian envoy leaves lingering
behind him
when entering and leaving this chamber
the air that we inhale
is filled with poisonous spores
of turpitude
when he dribbles torrential lies
as his lips begin moving
victory over the russia's army comes
closer by the day
as does the as does
the time when putin's henchmen
will seat on the bench at a trial for
war crimes and crimes against humanity
punishment
is imminent
and milosevic
will not stay lonely for too long thank
you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for their statement
i now give the floor to his excellency
mr peter glinski
deputy prime minister
and minister of culture and national
heritage of poland
thank you madam president
madam high commissioner
mr secretary general
distinguished members of the security
council
let me start by expressing poland's
appreciation and support for the
secretary's general's recent
trip to moscow and kiev
each and every effort to restore
peace in ukraine is meaningful
even if we have to deal with an
aggressor
who shows very little goodwill
and
trust worth
finished
as demonstrated by the very symbolic
russian shelling of kiev
during the secretary's stay
in the city
i was
also in kiev and borojnko
less than two weeks ago and witnessed
this war
on my own eyes
we post
we're very happy to facilitate
the
of mr secretary general
general and to host him on his way from
moscow to kiev
especially so because mr secretary
had a chance to meet with the polish
president anja duda and to stay in the
city of jesus which has become a crucial
hub
for the delivery and of assistance to
ukraine and the ukrainian people
as president duda assured the secretary
personally poland will not cease
to both
deliver aid on its own and to be a
reliable partner for all united nations
system institutions
involved in providing support for
ukraine
the numbers of the needy and the volume
of assistance they require
grow with every day the russian
aggression continues
therefore
we all need to contribute to the relief
efforts
alongside the growing
polish aid
both for the refugees from ukraine
staying in our country as you probably
know more than three million war
refugees have crossed
our border during two months
and those hiding from bombs in the
russian shell cities and towns today in
warsaw poland and sweden co-hosted a
high-level international donors
conference for ukraine
the event which was organized in
cooperation with president
of the european commission and the
european council
was
meant to serve as a platform for
pledging much-needed additional funds to
sustain immediate life-saving
humanitarian assistance for ukraine
according to early estimates the
conference brought 6.5 billion u.s
dollars in pledges
madam president
we are all still struggling to grasp the
full implication of this war
but we already know that it's a
consequences
go far beyond ukraine and europe
mr secretary general has accurately
called the damage to multilateralism
caused by the ongoing invasion of
ukraine
a three-dimensional crisis
a crisis impacting global food energy
and finance security
the ripe effects of the russian invasion
will be felt in economies and societies
around the whole world international
community needs to engage in devising
immediate and long-term policies
that will mitigate the impacts of this
war and contribute to long-term italians
to global shocks
in five days time on may
10th
some 50 sorry
okay 50 countries from europe and
central asia will gather in the polish
city of wooch
at the third
at the 33rd session of the good and out
of the food at agriculture organizations
regional conference for europe to
discuss the very pressing issue of
food security and agri-food systems
transformation
however
we will not solve the crisis of food
energy and
finance without addressing their root
causes
these are the crisis of values what was
already mentioned today by
madame president
and the crisis of peace so in fact
we are facing not just a
three-dimensional but five-dimensional
crisis
therefore
the very first step to take right now is
very simple it requires
russia to stop this war
and withdraw all its forces from the
ukraine territory
once peace is secured
the international community must turn
their efforts to develop more effective
measures to protect the fundamental
values
enshrined in the united nations charter
they have been tramped by a permanent
member of the security council and we
must ensure full accountability
for violation of international
humanitarian and human rights
law committed in ukraine by the russian
federation
thank you
i thank his excellency mr glinski for
his statement i now give the floor to
the representative of greece
thank you madam president we are
thankful to the u.s presidency for
organizing this meeting allow me also to
thank the secretary general
under secretary griffiths the high
commissioner for human rights miss
barcelo
for their insight remarks and the
immense efforts
also
miss tatiana luzan for briefing us
[Music]
madam president it is
the consequences of russia's continuing
military aggression against ukraine
among civilians are dire especially in
mario paul and near the former line of
contact in donbass greece has a
particular interest for the mario paul
area home to a centuries-long
established greek community of more than
120
000 a productive part of the local
societies alas these people along with
so many other civilians families women
children face the horror
as mario paul lies almost entirely
destroyed this is why our councils
in odessa and mario paul demonstrating
unprecedented courage strength and
altruism stayed behind and carried out
in total six operations called nostos
the greek word for homecoming for the
evacuations of greek citizens and
diaspora
greeks from ukraine
we have repeatedly called for an
immediate ceasefire and for the swift
operation of humanitarian corridors it
is of utmost importance to scale up
humanitarian operations by enhancing the
supply chain capacity and providing
targeted
humanitarian assistance to people
affected the recent evacuations in the
uh as of style plant and mario paul
achieved thanks to un um persistent
efforts demonstrated in the most obvious
way that when there is a will there is a
way we hope to see more initiatives like
this taking place
greece has been actively engaged in
providing humanitarian assistance our
minister of foreign affairs nicostendias
himself sparkheaded
one of greece's assistance operation to
the historic city of odessa
at the same time we all witness the huge
wave of migrants
this war has provoked greece is showing
solidarity to ukraine as well as to
front line member states welcoming
thousands of refugees from ukraine
madam president the amount of
devastation and destruction is
inconceivable greece remains engaged in
the reconstruction of ukraine and will
be present in coordination with our
partners in order to do everything
possible to bring back
these two cities
to the previous state and to facilitate
the diaspora greek's return to normal
life after this tragedy
our prime minister has already announced
that we are ready to rebuild a maternity
hospital destroyed by russian shelling
in the city of mario paul in the same
vein minister denis has reiterated our
support for the reconstruction of odessa
there can be no peace no
we consider econ necessarilization
without a accountability
we will continue to actively raise the
issue of mario paul in all fora and
emphasize that the perpetration of war
crimes should be thoroughly investigated
only peace can bring an end to this
immense tragedy with far-reaching
repercussions to the world over
we commend the recent visit of the
secretary general in the region and his
efforts towards peace
we stand firm in our call for dialogue
and diplomacy to prevail
greece a pillar of stability in the
region of eastern mediterranean and
beyond reiterates its unwavering
commitment
to international law and the u.n charter
refraining from threat or use of force
is the guiding principle underpinning
our charter
we are steadfast in our support to the
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity of ukraine as well as of every
u.n member state these are fundamental
norms of international relations their
violations no matter who
they target are threats to us all there
is no room for exceptions thank you
i thank the representative of greece for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative of latvia
thank you madam president i have the
warning to speak on behalf of the free
baltic states estonia lithuania and my
own country latvia
i thank the un secretary general general
antonio guterres high commissioner
bachelet usg griffiths as well as the
ocha and ngo representatives for their
insightful but sobering briefings
we appreciate the secretary general's
important visits to kiev and moscow in
particular
his humanitarian plea in engagement
which have resulted in very practical
life-saving humanitarian action on the
ground
notably in mariupol we also positively
note the close cooperation between the
un and the icrc in this regard
in the future the u.n should build
further on this also limited success
unfortunately these achievements are far
from solving the tragic security and
humanitarian crisis caused by the
russian aggression
moreover
many more people remain trapped in the
azov style iron and steel works complex
in conditions that humanitarian workers
have described as hell
yet it has been again under heavy fire
from the russian airstrikes we call on
russia to immediately seize all
hostilities and allow safe evacuation of
remaining civilians trapped in this
complex
we also call on all you relevant u.n
mechanisms to maintain their focus on
the situation of civilians affected by
the russian aggression in ukraine
especially on the rescue and evacuation
from the areas of persistent hostilities
madam president
it has been more than two months since
russia a permanent member of this
council
launched its aggression against ukraine
in grave violation of international law
including the founding principles of the
u.n charter
russia has persistently ignored the
calls of the u.n general assembly as
well as the order of the international
court of justice to seize aggression and
to immediately and unconditionally
withdraw all forces and military
equipment
from the entire territory of ukraine
we strongly condemn russia's contempt to
the u.n court
russia's military aggression against
ukraine as well as the involvement of
belarus as russia's accomplice
russia's unjustified and unprovoked
invasion of ukraine has triggered one of
the fastest growing displacement and
humanitarian crises on record
over 17 million people inside and
outside ukraine now are in the need of
humanitarian assistance
7.7 million people are now internally
displaced and more than 5 million
refugees have fled into countries
neighboring ukraine and beyond
ninety percent of refugees are women and
girls
they need urgent humanitarian assistance
a cessation of hostilities and safe
passage including through the creation
of humanitarian corridors to allow those
who wish to do so to live voluntarily to
the destination of their choice
in this light we are concerned about the
reports of hundreds of thousands of
ukrainians including children forcibly
moved to so-called filtration camps and
then to the territory of the russian
federation
often unaccompanied by their parents
madam president
russia's denials deceptions lies
disinformation war propaganda incitement
for violence and dehumanizing language
against ukrainians do not change the
fact that russia is committing war
crimes crimes against humanity and other
violations of international humanitarian
and human rights law against the
civilian population in ukraine
as underlined by the u.n secretary
general those directly responsible for
these war crimes and violations on
ukrainian soil must be held accountable
there will be no impunity
there will be accountability for this
horror and international justice will be
done
the baltic states will continue to
steadfastly support all efforts to
ensure independent and effective
investigations into crimes committed by
russia and ukraine
estonia latvia and lithuania we were
among the first to refer the situation
in ukraine to the prosecutor of the
international criminal court and we will
continue to support the office of the
prosecutor in its investigation
concerning alleged war crimes and work
crimes against humanity committed in
ukraine
madam president the impact of russia's
war against ukraine is reaching beyond
europe
millions of people globally are already
on the brink of famine and russia's
invasion will further exacerbate the
negative impact on global food security
and prices on the world market
therefore increasing the threat of
hunger to many countries
ukraine is world's fifth largest
exporter for wheat
however the shelling and bombing makes
it almost impossible for ukrainian
farmers to sow
on top of this
russian federation is blocking hundreds
of ships filled with the wheat in the
black sea
20 million tons of grain from the last
year's harvest have been trapped in
ukraine due to russia's blockade and
bombardment of odessa seaport and the
military closure of the sea lines in the
black sea
this is the result of the russian
aggression and not sanctions or anything
else as russia's propaganda suggests
we call on russia to unblock ukrainian
ports to restore the freedom of
navigation
and we encourage the security council
and the relevant u.n agencies to
consider the ways to ensure the safe
passage for grain-carrying ships from
ukraine
regrains territorial waters to the black
sea i thank you
i thank the representative of latvia for
your statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of italy
thank you madam president today's
interventions by the secretary general
the emergency relief coordinator and the
high commissioner for human rights
confirmed the extraordinary gravity and
the multi-dimensional character of this
senseless war
this is at the same time an unprovoked
military aggression a blatant violation
of the u.n charter by a permanent member
of the security council
as well as a humanitarian and human
rights crisis of dramatic proportions
from a political perspective we cannot
about reaffirming the fundamentally
illegal nature of this war
which violates the prohibition of the
use of force against the territorial
integrity and political independence of
a sovereign country
the obligation to settle disputes
peacefully and the prohibition of
targeting the civilian population
for this reason while we reiterate once
more our unwavering support for
ukraine's full independence within its
internationally recognized borders and
condemned
the russian military aggression
we appreciate and strongly support the
diplomatic initiative taken by the u.n
secretary general with his recent
mission to moscow and kiev
let me reaffirm our conviction that we
need to take urgent steps
towards peace
in the words of the un secretary general
guterres
achieving a wide and sustainable
ceasefire would be the first of these
steps
madam president from a humanitarian
perspective the conflict in ukraine is
not only fueling one of the most severe
humanitarian crisis in europe since the
world war ii
is also exacerbating a global food
security crisis
italy renews its call on russia to
ensure
safe rapid and unhindered access to
humanitarian assistance and to allow the
export of crucial ukrainian agricultural
goods
in order to alleviate also the
challenges faced by numerous states of
the global south depending on these
products
we also strongly supported the secretary
general's proposal for a humanitarian
contact group composed of russia ukraine
and u.n officials
italy has stood by ukraine and its
people since the beginning of this
crisis
with the
general budget support
loans
and support of the humanitarian
activities carried out
by the u.n system and the red cross in
ukraine and the neighboring countries
however as humanitarian needs continue
to increase as we speak we are
evaluating additional humanitarian
initiatives in terms of funding and
in-kind donations madam president
from a human rights perspective this
aggression is dramatically affecting
defenseless and innocent civilians
including those in most vulnerable
situations such as women children
elderly persons and persons with
disabilities
as documented by the human
rights monitoring mission in ukraine
russian armed forces have
indiscriminately shelled and bombed
densely populated areas
this is unacceptable and we strongly
advocate for the establishment of safe
passages for the evacuation of civilians
and i now give the floor to the
representative of germany
thank you madam president uh and i thank
the secretary general under secretary
general griffith high commissioner
bachelet and mrs luzon for their
insightful briefings
further i want to thank the secretary
general and all u.n staff for their
tireless efforts to minimize the human
suffering in ukraine
and neighboring countries
germany strongly supports these efforts
we were relieved about the successful
evacuation operation from my rupaul
the people remaining trapped need to be
safely evacuated as soon as possible to
the destination they want to go to
excellencies in a few days the world
will commemorate the day when the second
world war unleashed by nazi germany
ended 77 years after this watershed
moment of world history russian
propaganda tries to create an outrageous
link between the truly heroic fighting
of the red army including many
ukrainians fighters then against the
nazi regime
and the kremlin's current aggression
against ukraine
this apparently aims at creating and
completely alternate reality in which
ukraine's president leads a failed state
that needs to be denasified
this utter nonsense is beyond cynicism
the whole world can see what so-called
russian liberation looks like the
pictures from mariupol from urpin and
buja speak for themselves
these mass atrocities and crimes against
humanity have to stop
the perpetrators must be held
accountable in accordance with
international law
to this aim germany will contribute to
the international criminal court with
additional funding and secondment of
experts meanwhile the german federal
public prosecutor general has opened
structural investigations preparing the
ground for indictments on charges of war
crimes
even if russia again tries hard in
tomorrow's area formula meeting to
impose its narratives on the world
outside it will not succeed in altering
reality
rapes torture and killings will be
brought to the fore the ones responsible
will be brought to justice one by one
madam president millions of peoples are
fleeing from attacks from bombing and
shelling
germany has so far recorded more than
600 000 refugee arrivals and over 90 000
ukrainian children are attending at
least temporarily german schools
it is children that suffer the most from
russia's war of aggression
their schools are being destroyed these
kids peaceful lives have been disrupted
many had to leave their families behind
all this
and all they want is to go home and
return to their beloved ones
in this connection reports about the
russian parliament planning to ease
rules for the adoption of ukrainian
children are extremely concerning
we will follow this ideologically
motivated motion with extreme scrutiny
and hold russia accountable for its
deeds un agencies as well should play an
active role in this regard
the war in ukraine has dramatic
consequences on humanitarian crises in
other parts of the world and on global
food security
russia ravages agricultural potential in
ukraine
while at the same time preventing grain
exports by blocking the black sea and
absurdly tries to blame western
sanctions for increasing food prices
currently an estimated 4.5 million
tonnes are stuck in ukrainian
ports and the ukrainian representative
here in this meeting
has reported that russia has stolen tons
of grain from ukraine
with the expected delays of the next
plan planting season and shortages of
seeds we are standing on the brink of an
unprecedented global food security
crisis
germany is strengthening its
humanitarian response especially through
wfp we are also committed to putting
global food security high on the agenda
among others in the upcoming meetings
meetings of g7 foreign development and
agricultural ministers
the german government has also already
announced 130 million euros in
additional funding for the crisis
response outside ukraine this is
additional to the means we have been
able to pledge for ukraine including in
the warsaw conference
my message to the countries economically
affected by the repercussions of
russia's law of aggression is you can
count on our support
the food security crisis proves that the
water and sends the borders of europe a
permanent member of this council is
trying to annex new lands by force
if we allow russia to set a president
who will be next which former empire
will feel encouraged to attack its
weaker neighbor justifying this by a
distorted notion of history if we do not
want to open floodgates for
recolonization
the world must stand united in rolling
back russia
we once again call on russia to stop its
aggression immediately
russian troops encounter fierce
resistance not only from the brave
ukrainian military but from a huge block
of states that stand up for the un
charter and the rule of law
continuing the senseless war will only
lead to my bloodshed and it is never too
late to change course
russia must withdraw its troops now and
for good the upcoming day of liberation
that we all commemorate will provide an
excellent opportunity thank you
i thank the representative of germany
for their statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjoined